l'heure est à la réouverture après trois
ans de travaux le grand appartement de
la reine a retrouvé de sa superbe de la
salle des gardes à la chambre les quatre
salles et été rénovée la salle des
gardes
elle a fait l'objet d'un très gros
chantier de restauration avec un mécénat
important d'aidé américaine friends
versailles et de la société des amis de
versailles restauration du plafond peint
au vin de grands plats font pas du
château de noël quoi peine et puis
restauration complète aussi des parois
du décor de marbre des plans doré de
toute cette ambiance très louis xiv
dans la chambre de la reine témoin de
trois règnes c'est le plafond qui
dévoile ses secrets
lourdement rénové au 19e siècle y révèle
aujourd'hui des subtilités du sionisme
jusqu'à une époque récente les
restaurateurs n'avaient pas beaucoup de
scrupules et avait tendance à recouvrir
très largement plutôt que de dégager la
crasse et de restituer l'original on a
beaucoup recouvert repas et on s'est
rendu compte que ce plafond finalement
ne ressemblait plus à ce qu'il était à
l'origine
si la chambre était la dernière pièce de
l'appartement au temps des souverains la
visite se fera en sens inverse
en arrivant de la galerie des glaces
[Musique]